welcome to this
tutorial on sudo boolean solving and
optimization
which is part of the boot camp for the
satisfiability theory practice and
beyond program at the simons institute
for the theory of computing
i am jakob noorchstram from the
university of copenhagen and lund
university
so this pre-recorded part of the
tutorial has four parts part one is on
pseudo-boolean preliminaries and then in
part two i'll talk about
solving of decision problems and in part
three
uh about optimization problems when
we're optimizing some objective function
and then there will be a fourth part
about mixed
integer linear programming and the video
will be divided into
these four parts and so this is the
first part
on sudo boolean preliminaries
and i'll talk about
what sudo boolean functions and
constraints are
what suru boolean solving and
optimization means give the formal
definition and then give some references
for
further reading so what is
a pseudo-boolean function or a
constraint what does pseudo-boolean mean
apart from being a cool name
well it's simply what theoreticians
would refer to
as a function over the boolean hypercube
to the real so the inputs
are boolean variables zero one valued
and the outputs of a pseudo boolean
function is a
is a real number and these pseudo
boolean functions have been studied
um since the 1960s in
in operations research and in integer
linear programming
we are interested in two restricted
version first where the functions f can
be represented as
polynomials and in fact throughout this
tutorial will be even more restrictive
and consider functions that are
representable as
linear forms and it turns out that this
is a
rich formalism for expressing different
kinds
of optimization problems so many
problems can be
described as optimizing some some linear
objective function under linear
pseudo-boolean constraints
so why would we do pseudo-boolean
uh optimization when we have sat after
all the name of the program is
is the sat program but we also want to
go beyond and one reason to go
beyond sat to sudo boolean is that it's
a richer format than the conjunctive
normal format used in sat for instance
if i want to write down
that the sum of six boolean variables is
at least three
then in pseudo-boolean format i can just
write down this
inequality whereas if i write it as
clauses
then i need this big chunk of clauses
where we have just to make sure we're
on the same page regarding notation so
these are disjunctive clauses x1
or x2 or x3 or x4 is the first clause
and then all the clauses are added
together
and it can be verified that
a boolean assignment satisfies all of
these clauses simultaneously
if and only if their sum is at least
three
okay so not only uh is the pseudo
boolean format more expressive
but the kind of reasoning that we can
use
pseudo boolean reasoning turns out to be
exponentially stronger
than the resolution based reasoning that
underlies conflict-driven clause
learning which is the
dominant paradigm in stat solving
and yet sudo boolean the pseudo-boolean
format
is close enough to set so that we can
benefit from all the developments
that have happened in sat solving since
the turn of the millennium
and since sudo boolean
problems are just another name in fact
for zero one integer linear
programs as we will see this means that
we can also use ideas from zero and
interior linear programming and try to
exploit synergies and in fact a lot of
what this tutorial is about
is how to combine ideas from from
sat from zero one integer linear
programming and
and maybe other areas to
construct good solvers
so what is the pseudo boolean constraint
well throughout
this tutorial a pseudo boolean
constraint is going to be a
0 1 integer linear constraint so it's a
linear sum
of literals that is variables or negated
variables for the semantics is that
x plus x bar so the negation of x is
equal to one
and the a's are all integers
and then the bow tie is some kind of com
comparator so greater than equal less
than equal or equality or
strict inequality and variables as we
said take boolean values we think of
zero as false and one as true
in fact we're going to without loss of
generality use
normalized form where
constraints are always written as
greater than or equal constraints
and all coefficients
are non-negative integers and also the
constant term
on the right hand side is a
non-negative integer and when a
constraint is written in normalized form
this constant term is referred to as the
degree of falsity or
just the degree of the constraint
so the clauses that we have in a
conjunctive
normal form c formula are just
pseudo-boolean constraints we sum up the
literals in the clause and require
that at least one of them should be true
we just saw a cardinality constraint
that's another
special type of pseudo-boolean
constraints that generalizes
uh clauses and then of course you can
have uh general sudo boolean constraints
like x1
plus x 2 x 2 bar plus 3 x
plus 4 x 4 bar plus 5 x 5
and greater equal 7 say
okay and in fact it's not hard to see
that this conversion to normalize form
is
is without loss of generality for
instance if we have
this uh constraint suppose we have the
constraint minus x1 plus 2x2
minus 3x3 plus 4x4
minus 5x5 and we want this to be
strictly negative then in order to turn
this into normalized form
we can first make the inequality
non-strict strictly smaller than zero
just means less equal minus one
and then to turn it into greater than or
equal we multiply by
minus one and
in the next step we want to make all the
coefficients positive
and we do this by replacing a negative
literal minus l by minus 1 minus l bar
so if we do this we get an x
minus 2 times 1 minus x 2 bar
plus 3 x minus four
times one minus x four bar
plus five x five greater equal one and
now we collect
all the constant term and shift them to
the right hand side we get
in fact the boolean the pseudo boolean
constraint we had before
x1 plus 2x2 bar plus
3 x3 plus 4x4 bar
plus 5x5 greater equals 7. and
it should not be too hard to see that
this will work in general also if we
have an equality
uh we just replace that by two
inequalities a greater than equality
greater than equal and a less than equal
equality and then we do this
transformation for
both of these constraints um
so in view of this we will always think
of constraints as being in normalized
form but we can also freely allow
ourselves to use
syntactic sugar when convenient so if we
have a
linear form a i l i where the sums of
the coefficients
is m then a a strict
greater than um inequality
is just greater than or equal with the
a plus 1 instead of a and
less than equal equality sum a i
l i less equal a we just flip it around
and get
some a i l i bar greater equal
the total sum m of the coefficients
minus a
and then similarly for uh strictly less
than
and as we already said for equality we
replace it
by by two linear inequalities
so in the rest of this tutorial whenever
it is convenient
we will write the linear inequalities in
whatever form is convenient for us but
whenever
it matters we implicitly assume that all
constraints we're operating on
are normalized
another aspect that is worth commenting
on
is that we restricted our attention to
linear constraints but if we have
non-linear constraints say we have
a polynomial sum
of a i m i for i goes from 1 to k
greater equal a where the mis
are monomials and we can in fact write
this
as a collection of linear constraints we
can linearize
we can introduce fresh variables y i
for each monomial mi and write
the linear sum uh a i
y i greatly equal a and then we specify
for each y i that
y i is one if and only if
all literals in the monomial r1
so this is possible but we won't
talk more about this during this
tutorial we'll for the rest of this talk
we'll have
we'll only consider linear constraints
some convenient notation that we will
use
should be fairly obvious but just to
make clear what it means if we have two
constraints then we can take their sum
if we have a constraint on a linear form
then i can just add this linear form
to the constraint given a positive
integer i can multiply
a linear constraint by that positive
integer and so
we'll use this notation and again
assuming that these
resulting constraints are normalized
whenever this matters
some further notation that can sometimes
be convenient and i
mentioned this also just to make sure
that we are familiar with how
constraints work and how we can play
with them uh if i have
a pseudo boolean constraints c
sum a i l i greater equal
capital a where i use this dot equality
throughout the talk
to denote syntactic equality and the sum
of the coefficients
again is big m then the
negation of this constraint is also a
pseudo boolean constraint in fact it's
the same thing as the normalized form
of sum of a i l i strictly less than
a i
can also have so-called refined
constraints where i have a new variable
z and i can write down constraints
saying for instance that
if that is true then the constraint c
holds and this would if you think about
that this would be the constraint
capital a times not z plus
i l i greater equal a where a is the
degree of falsity so
and in the other direction i can say
that the constraint
implies that z is true for a fresh
variable z
by writing down the constraint
m minus a plus one times z
plus sum of a i l i bar
greater equal m minus a plus one and if
you just
um take a minute offline
you verify that indeed these constraints
mean what the notation suggests that
they should mean
and in fact you can do the calculations
that if i take any constraint c
and not c and i add them up then i get
contradiction
which is saying what we know namely that
both
constraints cannot really be true
simultaneously
so contradiction is zero greater equal
one
um uh the reification constraints saying
that the constraint c implies z is in
fact the same thing
as saying that not z implies
not c which is also easy to verify and
it seems natural
and the way we can play with three fight
constraints that
is that if i have derived now that z is
true so z greater equal one
and i multiply it with the degree of the
constraint c
and then add this to the constraint
z implies c then indeed i get c back
and in a similar way if i take
the constraint saying that c implies z
and i add the constraint c to it
then i get that z is true in fact i get
that z times the degree
of falsity of the negated constraint is
one but clearly that implies that z is
one
okay so i'm saying this just to to play
around with the constraints to make sure
that we're on the same page
so a pseudo-boolean formula now
is simply a conjunction of
pseudo-boolean constraints and so
sometimes we can write this
as the set of constraints here i um
write it down as a conjunction of the
constraints to make explicit that we
in order for the pseudo boolean formula
to be satisfied all constraints should
be satisfied
and pseudo boolean solving is the
problem given
a pseudo-boolean formula to decide
whether it is satisfiable or whether it
is feasible as another
term that is used for this a
suitable an optimization problem is
where we have in addition to a pseudo
boolean formula
f also an objective function which i'll
tend to write
sum of i summing over i
w i l i and we want to minimize
the subjective function so whenever we
have a pseudo boolean optimization
problem in this talk we always want to
minimize the objective and this is of
course without loss of generality
because if we want to maximize we can
just negate the objective function and
then minimize that
instead
i said that sudo boolean
optimization allows us to express
many problems in a natural and concise
way and just to give some examples of
this
if g is an undirected graph and
we have a weight function on the
vertices v
then weighted minimum vertex cover
is simply asking for a vertex cover so
we have a variable for
every vertex these are the
vertices we're choosing to be included
in the cover
so a vertex is in the cover if xv is one
and for every edge we want one of the
endpoints in the cover but then we want
to minimize the cost of the cover
so summing over the cover summing up the
weights of all these vertices
another problem that is similarly easy
to express
is weighted maximum clique so in a
clique we want to pick
as many vertices
v as we can with the restriction that if
uv is not an edge then
we cannot pick both u and v so under
this
restriction we want to maximize the sum
of the chosen vertices or
since we're assisting on minimization we
just add a negation in front
finally another problem slightly more
general that
will be relevant later in this tutorial
is weighted minimum hitting set so here
we have
a collection of sets living in some
universe and we have a again a weight
function
on all the elements in the universe and
we want to find a hitting set so a
hitting set
is just a set that has a non-empty
intersection with all the sets in our
collection
and for such a hitting set we're looking
at one
of minimal weight so summing up
all the weights of the chosen
elements in the set the weight should be
minimal
it's not hard to see that this is just a
generalization of vertex cover
and the sudo boolean optimization
formalization of this is again just
we're minimizing the linear sum of
all the variables one variable per
element
times its weight under the restriction
that for every set at least one element
in it should be chosen
and it's worth noting that in fact all
of these examples that i gave
are even more restricted than general
sulu boolean optimization problems
in fact here we're asked to optimize a
linear function
subject to just the c and formula
because all the constraints we see are
just clauses
so already this is a quite an expressive
framework although in general
of course it might be that the
constraints should also be general
pseudo boolean constraints
so what we will
talk about in the rest of this tutorial
is first we're going to talk about
pseudo boolean solving
and optimization basically
um what i mean by this is that we're
going to
start with uh sat solving and inspired
by satsang
we're going to take these
conflict-driven
techniques and try to lift them to the
pseudo boolean setting
and this is what most of the tutorial
will be about
then we'll also talk about the very
closely related topic of max sat solving
and then in the final part of the
tutorial
we'll talk about integer linear
programming or more generally
mixed integer linear programming or or
mip
and
very roughly um one can say that an
interesting difference between these
approaches is that
uh for for uh sat solving and
pseudo-boolean solving
you are always doing boolean reasoning
and you're focusing on finding integral
solutions so
zero one solutions and trying to zoom in
on the optimal one
in some sense integer linear programming
or mixed integer linear programming
tends to operate
uh from the other direction uh you
relax the problem and find optimal
non-integral solutions and then from
there you
try to search for
good integer solutions nearby as it were
and for but for all of these settings
a basic trade-off that we will see
several times during this talk is the
trade-off between
inference power versus inference speed
where
some solvers will optimize
being very very smart although this
takes more time and other
solvers sacrifice
intelligence maybe for speed and hoping
that raw
speed will compensate for being slightly
dumber with your
inference
although this will be a
[Music]
somewhat long collection of videos
it will still be only a very very
selective
survey of this area so some references
for further reading will
four chapters in the handbook of
satisfiability that is just out the
second edition
is being printed and distributed as we
speak
and it's a fantastic book in particular
i can recommend
chapter 7 on proof complexity and set
solving which contains a lot of the
material i'm going to talk about
also chapters 23 and 24 on max sat
um and chapter eight
uh also contains material on on pseudo
boolean solving
for mixed integer linear programming
there is nothing in the handbook of sat
but a good starting point
might be these papers
that i'm linking to here and then
um for
macsat and mixed interdilinear
programming i can also recommend
the tutorials the maxset tutorial at
echi20 last year and for map
there's a very nice tutorial by ambrose
gleichner
at a workshop in oaxaca
a couple of years back and those will
give
more details on maxsat and map which are
topics that are
not so well covered in this tutorial so
with this
i conclude the first part of
the tutorial on pseudo-boolean solving
and optimization
where we just uh surveyed the
preliminaries next up we're going to
talk about
how to solve sudo boolean decision
problem how to determine
whether pseudo boolean formula pseudo
boolean formulas are are
satisfiable or feasible and then later
on we'll talk about different ways of
optimizing